e
zéro avec 10 % au quatrième.
- Je suis vraiment de bonne
humeur. Ça va en prendre
beaucoup pour me faire
fâcher aujourd'hui...
- François Legault savoure
son début de semaine.
- Bonjour! Bonjour! Bonjour!
- ... après des jours difficiles
à défenà défenà défendre sa gesn
de la pandémie dans les CHSLD.
(acclamations)
La victoire de Shirley
Dorismond dans Marie-Victorin
lui permet de tourner
les projecteurs vers
ses adversaires, qui tentent
de justifier leur défaite.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
parlementaire, Québec solidaire
- À Québec Solidaire, une des
clés de nos succès, c'est le
vote des jeunes. Ce vote-là,
on a eu de la difficulté
à le faire sortir dans Marie-
Victorin, notamment parce dans
les élections partielles, il n'y
a pas de vote sur les campus.
Solidaire a vu
ses appuis fondre de sept points
de pourcentage par rapport
à l'élection générale de 2018,
malgré une visibilité médiatique
plus grande.
(cris et applaudissements)
Le Parti Québécois, lui, a
perdu son château fort depuis
40 ans, après une lutte serrée.
- C'est un excellent résultat!
- Le chef se défend d'être
dans le déni : si la CAQ n'a pas
réussi à faire mieux, malgré
sa popularité nationale,
c'est à cause de la rivalité
du PQ, selon lui.
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chef, Parti québécois
- Pour lgénérale,
dans Marie-Victorin, il y a
qu'un seul parti qui peut
battre la CAQ, c'est nous.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
cheffe, Parti libéral du Québec
- Je dois faire le constat
avec beaucoup d'humilitéde ce q.
- Seule la cheffe libérale fait
un mea culpa. Dominique Anglade
reconnaît ne pas avoir entendu
ses membres, qui voulaient
l'entendre parler d'économie
et de libertés individuelles,
elle qui tente un virage
progressiste qui semble peu
populaire auprès de sa base.
- J'ai jamais dit que ce serait
facile non plus d'opérer
un tel virage.
- S'il y a un message, hier,
important pour Dominique
Anglade, c'est de dire :
"C'est bien beau lancerde la bos
n'aiment pas ça."
- François Legault lui donne des
leçons, mais le premier ministre
doit tout de même garder un oeil
sur son rétroviseur : le Particx
que les libéraux à Longueuil.
es partis politiques
méritent notre attention.
- Et cette attention se tournera
vers la région de Québec.
Si Éric Duhaime a réussi
à hausser ses appuis dans
une circonscription qui n'est
pas réputée conservatrice,
qu'en sera-t-il de la Capitale-
Nationale à l'élection générale?
Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio-Canada, Qué